Dans « Pourquoi On Dit ? »,
je vous raconte cequi se cache derrière
les expressions de la langue française.
Alors abonnez-vous
et n'oubliez pas...
que je suis cloche !
Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Savez-vous,
pourquoi on dit
« avoir du bol » ?
Il s'agit vous savez,
d'une expression
signifiant
« avoir de la chance ».
Elle est apparue,
au XXème siècle
mais dans cette histoire
le bol
n'a rien àvoir
avec celui dans lequel on prend notre petit déjeuner.
Ce mot
vient ici de l'anglais
« bowl »
et désigne un récipient plus profond que large.
On le retrouve aussi en néerlandais
eten allemand
sous des formes assez similaires.
Dans toutes ces langues,
les racines européennesdu mot signifient
« enflé »,
« être enflé ».
Le mot « bol »
a ainsi pris avec le temps
un autre sens.
Enargot,
il désigne
la partie renflée,
bien connue,
de notre anatomie humaine :
le cul !
Voilà !
c'estdit.
« Avoir du bol »
est donc
une autre façon de dire
« avoir du cul ».
Autrement dit,
« avoir de la chance ».
La première,
pour argotique que soient ses origines,
est devenue aujourd'hui
plus polie que la seconde
pour parler de la bonne fortune.
Avec un peu de chance
ou de bol,
je suppose que vous avez déjà deviné
que dans l'expression :
« en avoir ras-le-bol »,
le bol du petitdéjeuner
n'a rien à voir non plus.